some breaking news to bring you now and
the
directors of public health in greater
manchester are asking anyone who's
traveled
to the city region from any tier iv area
or from wales to self-isolate for at
least 10 days
when they arrive and those 10 days
should start from
saturday the 19th of december that means
remaining inside the house where they're
staying for a whole
10 days other people who live in the
house don't need to self-isolate unless
anyone
gets symptoms but no visitors should be
allowed
into that house at all even on
christmas day and this is in response to
the new strain of covid
which dr janelle de grucci director of
public health in thames side says is
increasing rapidly
in tier 4 areas and is extremely
worrying we are so concerned about the
potential grave impact of this
that we've taken the difficult decision
to ask anyone who's traveled here
for christmas to act as if they have
this new variant even if they have
no symptoms and self-isolate for at
least
10 days